I can't believe it's been 20 years still
gonna take father into the anniversary
we wouldn't be here if it wasn't for him
on this day in 1996 the world escaped
the clutches of extinction your father
was the bravest man I've ever seen we
all lost someone we love
but in their sacrifice we found the
technology to build a stronger and safer
earth
because our survival is only possible
when we stand together
oh my god a distress call
- screaming they're not screaming
they're celebrating they're giving back
it has its own gravity
what goes up must come down shouldn't we
be nervous um yeah
our whole lives built up to this moment
it's touchdown over the Atlantic let's
buy all of it
make them pay not going out there to
make friends we've gotten remind them
earth is not for the taking
Oh
five years to get us ready we're going
down I never had a chance we didn't last
time either we convinced an entire
generation
this is a battle that we could win we
sacrifice for each other no matter what
the cost
that's worth fighting for support the
July let's show them some fireworks
they like to get the landmarks
I'm earth space defense director David
Levinson I got some handy tips on how we
can all help save the earth so you know
it's not always just up to to me by
myself first don't be a water waster you
got to turn up your showers and sauces
second reduce food waste by using your
freezer more shop in your own fridge
just common sense third and of course
don't try this at home but if you see an
alien city destroyer hack their code
alert the president fly up to the alien
ship and upload a deadly computer virus
also having one of these handy kind of
kind of helps so once again it's David
Levinson reminding you and anybody else
that's listening don't mess with earth